First of all, we should address the elephant in the room,
which is that your Christmas tree is still up
and your ornament is still.
Barbie's still here? Yeah,
she's here to protect us. She's not doing a great job.
Yeah, she needs to step it up.
Today's episode
we discuss something that has been going around the internet
called the Dating Matrix. The dumb, smart, evil,
sweet dating matrix. Yes,
and we're gonna show you what it looks like.
Okay, so draw.
Cause it's science. It's scientific,
it's important. Oh no, no,
that is weird. Why did I do it that way?
This is why teachers are heroes.
Yes, truly.
And must be protected at all cost.
On the right we have. We have sweet.
The left. That is a left.
On the second quadrant. Third quadrant. Quadrant.
I'm still learning. I thought it was a graph.
Haha.
Sweet
and dumb. Here we have sweet, smart,
evil and dumb.
And here we have evil and smart.
What's your order?
What's yours?
This looks. Can I see it